with everything going on in the world
today it's hard to figure out which
subjects are truly newsworthy and
deserving of an open discussion which is
why I would like to formally state and
go on the record here saying that uh
that will.i.am was completely out of
line
okay it's obvious to me that he was a
whole instigator in this confrontation
and no matter how childish Perez Hilton
may have acted there is no excuse I mean
who is will.i.am think he is Sean Penn
circa 1985 you can't go around knocking
people out even if you are married to
Madonna violence is never the answer
ever and Brazil why does he get away
with using the gay slur shouldn't hate
speech laws be blind you're a [ __ ]
you're gay and stop being such a [ __ ]
all I know is if the black IP should
really be called the four Fergie's and
we'll knows it not to mention or the the
new death tolls on the Iranian
protesters actually supposed to be
covered no that's stupid
you're not gonna live to see 30
seriously though I don't know why Perez
gets a free pass here I mean sure we'll
shoot Nevada's manager hit him but that
doesn't make it okay